-Thank you very much for
watching "The Tonight Show."
I appreciate it, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Let's get to the news and jokes.
Well, guys, the big news today
is that President Trump
has been released
from Walter Reed hospital.
Here's a message
from his doctor earlier today.
-He's met or exceeded
all standard
hospital discharge criteria.
He'll receive another
dose of Remdesivir here today,
and then we plan to
get him home.
Though he may not entirely be
out of the woods yet,
the team and I agree that
all our evaluations,
and, most importantly,
his clinical status
support the president's
safe return home.
-Yep. Good news?
It's safe for
the president to return home,
mostly because everyone at
The White House
already has the virus.
When she heard
he was coming home,
Melania immediately checked
herself into Walter Reed.
But this was nice.
The staff went all out
to welcome Trump home.
They even hung
a bunch of balloons
that looked exactly like
the coronavirus.
Yep, Trump left the hospital
for two reasons.
One, he was feeling better.
Two, he didn't want to
get billed for another night.
[ As Trump ] I know
how these things work.
[ Normal voice ]
A reporter then asked about
Trump's mental status, like if
he has any neurological symptoms
or fogginess as a result of
having the virus,
and here is what the doctor
had to say.
-I think you have seen
the videos and now the tweets,
and you'll see him shortly.
You know, he's back, yeah.
-The reporter was like,
"Yeah, we did.
That's why we're asking you."
Some crazy times when you can
judge the president's health
from his videos and tweets.
This afternoon, Trump broke
the news on Twitter,
saying, "I'll be leaving the
great Walter Reed Medical Center
today at 6:30.
Feeling really good.
Don't be afraid of COVID.
Don't let it dominate your life.
I feel better than I did
20 years ago."
I'm not surprised Trump feels
better than he did 20 years ago.
Back then,
he was $800 million in debt.
Trump left Walter Reed today,
but he actually left
the hospital for a little while
over the weekend. Watch.
-The president got in his S.U.V.
and went out
to wave to supporters
gathered outside.
-He's there in the back seat,
wearing a mask and waving.
Others in the S.U.V.
with him exposed.
Health experts say the president
likely still contagious.
-Yeah, according to
"The New York Times,"
Trump wanted to leave
the hospital,
and doctors wanted him
to stay inside,
so they compromised,
and Trump left the hospital.
Yeah, the Secret Service
had to take Trump around
after 50 Uber XL drivers
were like, "Hell no."
What is happening?
Trump even turned
a hospital stay into chaos.
The Joker caused less trouble
when he visited Gotham General.
You could tell
the Secret Service
thought the joyride
was a bad idea.
Right after, they went on eBay
looking for a used Popemobile.
Well, it turns out
Trump's joyride
may have even his own
family thinking
he is acting irrationally.
According to sources,
Don Jr. is deeply upset
by his father's decision
to drive around
and thinks Trump
is acting crazy.
You know things have gone off
the rails when Don Jr.
becomes the voice of reason.
In response,
President Trump was like,
"I'm not acting crazy,
and here's 15 all-caps tweets
to prove it."
Meanwhile, on Saturday night,
The White House
released some photos to
show that Trump was busy working
while he was at Walter Reed.
Here is one of
Trump signing a document.
Could we zoom in on that?
People are saying that
he's just writing his name
on a blank piece of paper,
but that's not true.
That's not true.
That's not
a blank piece of paper.
That's just his entire plan
to stop COVID.
It seems like a photo op,
but they've really just been
handing Trump blank pages to
sign for the past four years.
"This is urgent, Mr. President."
[ As Trump ] Oh, well,
then I have to sign it.
[ Normal voice ] Well,
some people online are calling
the announcement ceremony
for Amy Coney Barrett
"The Rose Garden Massacre"
after it's been identified as
the super-spreader event.
Take a look.
Yeah.
By the way, could those seats be
packed together any tighter?
Even the C.E.O. of Southwest
was like,
"Come on,
give him a little room."
Right after that photo,
Trump was like,
"Okay, now let's all get
in a big pile."
Let's change gears.
I saw that Coca-Cola announced
that they are discontinuing
their coconut-water brand Zico.
It's a big blow for all of
those people who love pretending
that they like
the taste of coconut water.
-Hey! Hey!
-Coca-Cola knew it was time
to discontinue Zico
because they actually did it
a year ago, and no one noticed.
And, finally, this is exciting.
A pretty famous house
just got put on the market.
Watch this.
-The house that played a central
role in the 1991 thriller
"Silence of the Lambs"
is for sale
for the price of
just under $300,000.
Fans of the movie can buy
the on-screen Pennsylvania home
of the fictional serial killer
Buffalo Bill.
-Man, I know people are buying
a lot of houses right now,
but you've got to draw
the line somewhere, right?
Yeah, Realtors say
they'll be happy to give you
a tour of the front porch
and nothing else.